*Triple H's Time to play the game begins in the background*
*Hater blocking face*
Ya'll think I care? Do I Iook like I give a shit? I am the coolest motherfucker on this planet
Do you think some little kids spouting shit online is going to make me quit?!
FUCK YOU for even thinking that for a second
I'm gonna review your petty little piece of shit videos, and that'll be it!!
Please don't be mean ;~;
I don't know how long I can keep this façade up
Let's watch the first video of the first hater
Hater: Yea... we're here and we're gonna talk about how Pewdiepie
how he sucks ASS-HOLES
You can't even suck Ass-holes
*FACT*
Its a round object
It's a round object, look at this *Smooching sound*
How will I suck it?
And his girlfriend is gay
Wha..? How did you know?
*Throws Glasses in disbelieve* HOW DID YOU KNOW?!
You guys are just faggots. Like I bet Pewdiepie has like this hypnotizing thing
And you guys all got hypnotized and now you're all faggots in the gay army.....yea, Pew- *video cuts*
*Pewds laughs* Oh he cut off *more laughing* that's brilliant
*kid comes back but now he's too close oh my god* And you guys all got hypnotized
It's not true goddammit I am not hypnotizing you
I am not hypnotizing anyone
And especially not Marzia [You believe PewDiePie]
I must conserve my energy, this hater is not worth it
*Epic dewds jump in* Pewdiepie sucks!
Hater 1: He's a complete joke!
His back-up bud: We hate Pewdiepie!
We are better gamers than him!
*Pewds slightly triggered* Dillion the hacker says I'm gonna hack you to the end PewDiePie
That was a scam! We are for reals!
WE'RE THE REAL DEAL!!!!!!!
Pewdiepie--
The cringe, make me want to kill myself [fuking do it]
Why do you have so many subscribers Pewdiepie?
Can you give me some subscribers?
Pewdiepie: No [You heartless billionaire >:( ]
*Realization*
*Confused* wha the f--
The fuck? that was it?!
*Removes Glasses in shock*
*Heavy breathing*
Pussy Destroyer: What's going on bros
Is this guy for re- what the f-?
My name am PEEEEWWDIEPIE
*Speaking different language?*
Is this becoming a meme now? To act like a fucking retard?
And hating on Pewdiepie? [Pretty much]
Because if that's the case,
You win.
BlockyKid917: Hey guys blockykid he- Blockykid... Pewds: blockykid917
Ni- nine one seven here
You don't even know your own name!
DUUUUDE
What the fuck! (Video playing in background)
Maybe next time!
Wel- lets listen to what he says
and
Today we will be talking about why I hate pewdiepie
Pewdiepie... He's just...............
a- a turd!!! [Get roasted!]
I'm just a turd....
(repeats) I am just a turd!
*Triple H's time to play the game begins in background+Trigger mode engaged*
I'M JUST A TURD?
WHO THE FUCK DO YOU CALL A FUCKING TURD?!?!
I'LL COME HERE AND TURD ON YOUR FACE!
[Poor banana ;~; ]
I DON'T CARE IF IT'S ILLEGAL
DO I LOOK LIKE I GIVE A SHIT?!?! [Yus]
HOW FUCKING DARE *BASS* YOU CALL A TURD
MY MOM CALLED ME A TURD!
HOW DARE YOU SPEAK TO ME LIKE THAT
FUCK YOU! YOU'RE A TURD!!!!
YOU'RE A TURD YOU CURLY FACED SON OF A BITCH
I WILL STAB YOU
*Snaps out of drama mode...*
Sorry 'bout that..
Motherfucking Malcolm: Pewdiepie haters are-
Oh my god it's Malcolm
One of my biggest general enemies
Malcolm has returned
Malcolm has had a long time to figure out a response
How can I prepare
For this about of fuckin'
For this absolute fucking inferno
That he's about to blaze upon me [Sacrifice JackSepticEye, QUICK!]
Malcolm, please spare me
"Haters are sucks dick"
"Why Pewdiepie haters are so mean"
I don't know thats why
I agree, pewdiepie haters are mean Malcolm
You make a great point
Thank you finally for trusting me
I really appreciate you finally building a little bit of trust
*buzzer noise* Squeaker Jr.: Pewdie,
Gaaaaay-
Oh that's real creative oh that's ya ho
*breaths in* [You okay Pewdie?]
ah
My number one insecurity
About being gay
How did you know about it?
"Pewdiepie is gay"
"He should have never existed"
*sad piano music begins playing* "Pewdiepie should kill himself"
"Or quit youtube"
"Screw the bro army"
'The bros are fat and should also kill themselves"
"Brofist, more like gayfist" [How fucking dare you? :O]
"Brofist, more like gayfist"
THE ROASTS
I CAN'T HANDLE THEM
Some random kid: A thousand dollars off of each one
*Sad Pewdiepie* Now tell me that is fair
Yeah, it isn't
S-stop
I gotta say, pewdiepie can be funny [Wait a second..]
Wha-
Wha- the fu-
MAKE UP YOUR GOD DAMN MIND DUDE!
*Oh god not again* THE FUCK YOU PLAYING ME S-SOM-SOME KIND OF GAME?!?!
Pewdiepie hater #9,552: I fricken don't want to see poodiepie on my front page at my youtube thing
Every fuckin' day
I'm sick and tired of it
Motherfucke-
*Hits camera with keyboard*
*Laughter while dude has a passive rage*
*breaths in* Ah dude
Professional Roaster: Pewdiepie are you fucking kidding me?!
"I can't fuckin stand you, you sonava (Son of a) bitch"
I think this guy's actually legit
"You're fucking useless youtuber you little cunt"
Woa- Woa- Heyyy
Heyyy
"You make fuckin' shitty content you faggot"
Jesus christ this guys is fucking blazing me
"You delete your youtube channel you faggot"
Pewds: No! Roastignkid1907: You make thousand of dollars
Maybe million of doll-
Thousands of dollars...
That's cute *laughs*
*Music begins in background*
*Ear Rape coming up, you've been warned* Are you Fuckin' kidding me and they're not even good
YOU FUCKING FAGGAAAAAAT
Jesus.. *Not done yet o.o*
KILL YOURSEEEEE
*gasping*
aah... Destroyed
*Face of a defeated man :(*
I have been destroyed
Everything I worked so hard to create
*Low pitched screeching*
My Youtube channel
It's over
[Look at what you have done ;___; ]
I give up
Roasting kid
*Continued low pitch screeching*
*Panda sex*
Has won
The war :(
Malcolm: PewDiePie hates you!
Robot: PewDiePie should kill himself
*Sad PewdiePie is sad*
PewDiePie, he's just...
a- a turd!
*The words "a turd" echoing in the background*
*Screeching slowly becoming more and more muffled*
*Triple H's time to play the game begins in the background*
Alright, listen up you fucking haters! [O shit!]
I don't care who you are
I don't care what your name is
I don't care what your age is
If you're a PewDiePie hater...
I will come to your house
And I will smash, your mum's ass-
Sorry, I will smash your
Door in, and I will
Eat up your pet!
And I will
Pee on your... I will fart on your... [Getting there Pewds]
God da.. I will fart on your pillow [There you go :)]
Fuck you! To all the haters
You can go, and unsubscribe
to yourself [OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO]
*Laughs*
Oh, that's so bad
Ah I love it <3